je n'ai tu as fais ce que tu pouvais
faire ce qui devait se passer maintenant
[Musique]
j'étais dix mille neut infaillible sur
cette terre de colère soit contre qui
avait vécu
non ça va me faire du mal d'avoir la
colère non non non non non on va pas
prenez soin de vous madame
prenez soin de vous j'allais en france
en suisse et après je vais revenir au
mali mais oui voilà incroyable non non
non vous prenez un engagement donc on
n'en rassure et c'est mon fils d'un gi
crois que tout va bien mais il faut
quand même que j'aille je tenai juste
élu saluer parce que j'ai pris cet
engagement si vous prenez un engagement
aller au bout de votre engagement
sinon vous aurez perdu votre raison
d'être sur cette heure raisonnable
attentes oise le jeu cadre certaines
choses tu n'iras pas où tu veux oui vous
vous reposez vous bien c'est un roc
[Musique]
ceyrac